[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to a brand
new attack on Titan video in this video
we will be counting down the top 10
facts about mecha sod that you need to
know in my opinion these are the most
important facts about her and her
character and I think that these facts
show what an important role she plays in
the world of attack on Titan now Mikasa
is one of my favorite characters in
attack on Titan along with Levi of
course and I had a great time making
this video in order to give you the full
picture of Mikasa as a character we will
have to get into some manga spoilers so
proceed with caution if you are new to
the channel don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell for more
attack on Titan and other anime videos
and if you enjoy these types of videos
and want to see more be sure to smash
that like button to let me know before
we get started I just want to let you
know that we are running a quick poll on
our Twitter about which of these
versions of our avatar looks better feel
free to follow us on Twitter and vote on
this poll and thanks to anime roars
official artist octoroo for redesigning
our avatar in such an awesome way if you
want to see more of her work her deviant
art page is in the description number 10
we know that nicka site is part of both
the Ackermann clan and the asian clan
and both of these are minority blood
lives on the island of parodies but did
you know that in chapter 5 of the manga
we actually see her arm being scarred by
her mother in order to form the mark of
the Asian clan this detail is easy to
miss in the manga and in the anime is
was actually changed so that Mika says
mother is simply teaching her how to sew
very little is known about the Asian
clan other than the fact that it appears
to be nearly extinct and this is why the
human traffickers who attacked me
because of parents wanted to take her
and her mother their unique features
meant that they would sell for a higher
price as horrible as that sound bonus
fact Mikasa means my house in
Spanish Micasa on the other hand is the
correct pronunciation of mikasa ackerman
name number nine there is still a lot
that we don't know about the Ackermann
clan while we did learn in chapter 93 of
the manga that they are a byproduct of
titan science the Ackerman's possess
unique powers and Mikasa awakens to
these powers during her confrontation
with the human traffickers when she was
still a child after Aaron killed the
first two human traffickers but was then
caught off guard by the third Mikasa
experienced a moment in which she felt a
great surge of power and knew exactly
what to do this is what happens when a
member of the Ackerman clan awakens to
their inner powers the Ackerman clan is
a minority bloodline that was at one
point in history close to the LDN royal
family possibly as royal bodyguards or
something along those lines but because
they were not LD and their memories
could not be altered by the founding
titan power and for this reason they
were mistrusted and persecuted until
they were almost exterminated and now
only a few known members remain we still
don't know what exactly being a
byproduct of Titan science means but we
can assume that the Ackerman's were
subject to some sort of scientific
experiment for my theory on how titan
power is related to science and what
titan science might actually mean check
out our why we see dinosaurs in the
attack on titan season 2 opening video
link in the description other members of
the occupant clan include levi of course
humanity strongest soldier and also
Kenny the Ripper another incredibly
skilled fighter number 8 Mika says
purpose in life is protecting Aaron but
this is not just because she is a
teenage girl with a crush on a guy aaron
saved my cousin's life after her parents
were murdered right in front of her and
his family adopted her when she had no
one else in the world because of Adam
Mikasa was able to awaken to her
ackerman powers and and and motivated
her and gave her a reason for living
when she had nothing in the world and no
one else to turn to
Mikasa also made a promise to Aaron's
mother Carla that she would all
always protect him and this promise is
something that is very important to me
Casa her connection to Edun and her
devotion to him is symbolized by the
scarf that Annan gave her after he saved
her from the human traffickers and she
continues to wear this scarf almost all
the time
fun fact the scarf was a dark almost
black color in the manga but this was
changed to a red color in the anime
number 7 much has been made of Nicolas
attachment to edit and some have
criticized Mikasa for being too fixated
on Aaron and not being independent
enough as a character however Mikasa has
been shown to stand up to ed indirectly
when she disagrees with him when Aaron
begins recklessly fighting with Jean or
Jean in chapter 2 of the manga Mikasa
literally picks him up and physically
takes him out of the situation also in
episode 2 of the anime right after they
are forced to flee wall Maria and become
refugees inside wall rows Mikasa even
punches it and after he loses his cool
and starts insulting Armin she then
forces Eden to eat the food that he had
thrown away in anger showing that while
Mikasa cares deeply for Aaron she has no
problem standing up to him when she
thinks that it is necessary number 6
there is an attack on Titan manga
spin-off that focuses on Annie and Mika
saw called Lost Girls in fact a new
attack on Titan three part original
animation DVD based on this spinoff has
recently been announced
these original episodes will be released
along with volumes 24 25 and 26 of the
manga so they will be coming out
December 8 2017
April 9th 2018 and August 9th 2018
fair warning these spin-off stories do
not directly influence what happens in
the main storyline and in fact the
Mikasa story is just her imagining what
the world would be like if the Titans
never existed so it is just an alternate
imaginary timeline in mycosis case and
in short these stories are filler number
5 Mikasa is currently
nineteen years old after the latest
time-skip in the manga she was only nine
years old when her parents were killed
and she was adopted by Erin's parents
and she was 15 for the majority of the
attack on titan storyline before this
latest time skill as such we see Mekas I
go from a carefree nine-year-old girl
who experiences a terrible trauma to a
15 year old girl who has nevertheless
already an impeccable soldier risking
her life to fight the Titans and now we
will get to see her as a 19 year old
adult woman I am very curious to see how
Mikasa has changed in the last four
years and how much stronger she has
become bonus fact attack on Titan has
been both criticized and praised for its
lack of fanservice some say that in a
world as brutal as the world of attack
on Titan where anyone could die at any
moment
more people would be looking to get
intimate with each other while they
still have the chance but none of this
is actually shown in the series others
say that the fact that attack on Titan
doesn't show fanservice is a good thing
because that would only take away from
the compelling storyline nevertheless
there is plenty of attack on Titan fan
art out there that makes up for this
lack of fanservice in the actual series
including this image parts of which we
use for our thumbnail I believe that I
found the original artist that created
this image with the help of soul maka so
I will leave a link to their page in the
description you can also find this image
pinned in the waifu wars channel of our
discord server link in the description
number 4
Mikasa is a superbly skilled fighter
with incredible potential
she is 170 centimeters or 5 foot 6
inches tall and she weighs 68 kilograms
or 150 pound which is a lot for her
height what the weight is likely related
to her immense strength and muscular
physique
Mikasa was the top ranked recruit in the
104th Training Corps and one of the best
trainees in the history of the military
she is always prepared to fight and she
usually doesn't let her emotions get the
better of her as is clear from the fact
that unlike Armin & Eren Mikasa doesn't
hesitate to fight any Reiner and Bertolt
even though these individual
were supposed to be their friend
although she is not as strong as her
fellow Ackerman clan member Levi she is
also much younger than him after the
latest time skip Mikasa is nineteen as I
already said and Levi is probably in his
mid to late 3000 Mikasa definitely has
the potential to become humanity
strongest soldier sometime in the future
number three Mikasa is shown to have
exceptional judgement throughout the
series her decision to threaten the
merchant and frost district to move his
cargo out of the way saves many lives
and her willingness to stand up to her
superiors when they wanted to kill edit
for being a Titan is the reason why
humanity within the walls is able to
fight back against the Titans using
Eden's Titan powers also Mika says
decision to disobey Han G's order to
stand down during Aaron's battle with
the female Titan results in the female
Titan ultimately failing in her attempt
to climb the wall and escape to safety
Mikasa is willing to do whatever it
takes to get the job done even if that
means standing up to Authority despite
the fact that as a soldier she was
taught to obey orders and this is an
extremely important characteristic for a
leader to have superior fighting skills
can easily be undone by a lack of good
judgement and although Mikasa does at
times lose her cool such as when she saw
that edit had died during the Battle of
Arras district we are all human and we
all make mistakes
but make us have strong judgement skills
combined with her superior fighting
abilities make her potential all the
more promising number two many believe
that mycosis character was partially
inspired by Tomoe Gozen a 12th century
female samurai warrior
Tamla was both beautiful and an
exceptional fighter her archery skills
were legendary and as a swordsman she
was said to be worth a thousand men
similarly in chapter 10 of the manga we
learned on Mikasa is considered to be as
valuable as a hundred average soldiers
Tom why golden was known for being the
most trusted captain of her master
minamoto no yoshitsune key and she was
said to be extremely dedicated to him
the two were also believed to be lovers
Moya is credited with killing multiple
well-known samurai of her era which was
an incredible achievement for a woman at
that time in the Battle of our Zoo it is
said that Tom way I wanted to fight to
the death to protect her master but he
commanded her to leave and escape as it
would have been dishonorable for her to
disobey she managed to escape and she
lived on for many years after that even
though her master was killed I am a bit
worried that this real-life story could
be a hint at the eventual ending of
attack on Titan knowing ISA Yama it is
possible that in the end and in might
die but Mikasa would live on after him
especially since we know that eden is
afflicted with the curse of Emir I don't
know I certainly wouldn't want to see it
and die but let me know in the comments
what you guys think how do you think
attack on Titan will end and fact number
one Mikasa is best girl
well there are other cute girls in
attack on Titan and other badass girls
and other girls who are cute and badass
and also really like potatoes Mikasa is
a great fighter with excellent judgement
and she is completely devoted to the one
she loves and what more could you
possibly ask for in a waifu seriously
though the number one fact is that
Mikasa is an excellent character overall
and the attack on Titan simply couldn't
be what it is without her the genius of
isa yama is that he doesn't rely on just
one main character to carry the series
Mikasa Eden and Armin all complement
each other as characters Aaron's drive
and determination Armand's intelligence
and strategic thinking and Micah's a
superior judgment and combat skills all
work together to advance the plot while
some people say that Mikasa is too
reliant on edit and that she isn't
independent enough the fact is that Eden
and Armin could never have achieved
their goals if Mikasa wasn't there to
push them and to protect them
Eren with his recklessness would have
gotten himself killed long ago and Armin
would never have found the courage to do
what needs to be done without Mikasa
this is why I think the Mikasa is a
pivotal character in attack on Titan and
I hope that through this video I was
able to not
we inform you about Micah's up but also
demonstrate that she is a great
character overall and that is this for
this video guys
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoy these videos and want to see more
be sure to smash that like button and if
you are new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell once again thank you for over
50,000 subscribers and be sure to stay
tuned to the channel because we got
plenty more attack on Titan content on
the way and until next time see ya space
cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]